and so the judges what are the judges
for they're there they're scoring the
guys and they're scoring the animal so
that's like the thing that a lot of
people don't realize is like every one
of these Bulls is getting judged so
that's why the guys want their they want
these animals to be as well taken care
of as athletic as they possibly can
because they're watching us a question
how difficult they are to ride back and
so they're marking them one two fifty
and then they're marking these guys one
two fifty on how easy they can make it
look or how stylish they can be or if
they're just floating by and just barely
getting by so you know they're they're
they're looking at the animal and the
rider and putting the scores together
and so when so when you go into the
final event when you go towards the end
you want to get your thinking okay I
have this many points right now yeah
this bull is like so now you have to
pick the best well you have to really
get out there on the best one oh yeah I
kind of evaluated okay I might be able
to take a mid-range bull right now
because I'm doing I'm up by so much
right now yep exactly a lot of guys will
try that strategy and you don't know
when you're on the bullet so then are
you thinking style like I'm trying to do
this with a certain Flair or are you
thinking I'm just trying to stay on this
animal so most the time you're just
you're just doing your job doing
whatever keeps you in the middle
staying on them but then if you're right
and plumb easy you'll see guys lift
their leg and it's actually spur in the
bull and it's getting you extra points
essentially so it's showing you're in
domination and you're controlling your
ride and you're making a bowl just look
easy and that's what the just so yeah so
you're competing so you're not just
trying to stay on for eight seconds
you're also trying to impress the judges
exactly you're trying to get as much
Flair in your ad as you can they upped
your score there's a lot more to it like
like you think about it I know that man
it's a seconds goes by so fast when you
think about it but when you're watching
so much happen so quick there's a lot
going on it's like watching Flint and
when people start a fire you know it's
like watching that exact process right
there yeah just trying to pack it all in
yep and do you go when so say when it's
it's your chance to go pick the bull
will you go look at them will you go
down and spend time looking at four
before that Sunday ride no you pretty
much those top Bulls you know exactly
you've seen them hundreds
before that's and then you get up on the
cage out there and it's with him and
they got a big screen of all the names
and once you say that they'll put your
name beside him mark him off so and on
the tell upon the action on the stuff
you see on television do you see them
pick the bulls or it's just matched up
once they show it it depends it depends
on where we're at and like obviously you
know TV produce and stuff because a lot
of times you know if he's got the number
one pick and that heartbreak kids in
there you know our fans at home on TV
they want to see it if that's not a
potential if there's not something big
right off the gate then they might not
show it on TV but in the arena it's
interesting because he has been getting
up the last few weeks and he'll look at
me and go what are you thinking I'm like
no bull rider don't put that pressure on
me
ya know I'm an open mind guy yeah you
whatever he thinks I can win on I'll
take dance I'm one of those guys like I
want to see guys be as high as they can
be every single time so that's that's
always my advice what's like kind of the
future of boron do you see a change in
do you see it is it great as it is it's
just gonna get better then Bulls are
they're producing them and breeding them
to just get better and better so it if
they don't keep doing that with the bore
out of soon there's not gonna be a guy
that rides all weekend because the Bulls
are just getting better so and numbers
have dropped and bore out as I think the
amount of actual riders yeah yeah it's
dropped overtime and we need to breed
some men back into this world and make
some bull riders out of them because why
do you think that is I want the truth I
think because society is so scared of
everything that like we're not you know
taking what what is it the hot off the
garden hose you know that hot hose that
ha hose hit ya like we're not literate
item we're not we're keeping kids in a
bubble all the time we're not letting
them get life experiences we're not
letting them get their arm broke on the
playground
we're so coddling yeah that we don't let
people have experiences and it's
something that you definitely have to
experience I mean and we just don't have
enough toughness in society yeah I mean
oh yeah we lose it out here I mean it's
gone I mean yeah many stuffs in the
ocean yeah it's a change thanks for
watching that video right there that was
a beautiful little segment I think
but of course I'm partisan to myself but
you can move on to another video right
now you could check on this video or on
this video that's two different options
and you can also subscribe to the
channel check on a new video subscribe
to the channel check subscribe check
gestures curse card